thank you for your time
what is the current situation on the
world's oil market
is it possible that the global demand
for oil gets back to the pre-crisis
level
the trend we are witnessing today makes
us optimistic
global consumption of oil has been
growing petrol consumption in europe
has already reached the level of 2019.
consumption of petrol and jet fuel has
been growing in the united states too
these factors indicate that the oil
price is getting back to the
pre-pandemic
levels hopefully this trend persists
populations of all the developed
countries which are the main consumers
of our product
are being actively vaccinated against
the virus this makes us optimistic about
the future
and the oil price today shows an
increase in demand for crude oil
when vaccines have been developed and
the situation with the curvy 19 pandemic
has become more stable has anything
changed for your business
have you felt the positive effects of
this change
well we are all still under stress
because the opec plus agreement is still
in effect
the limitations are still in place as
you know
the decision to increase oil production
was not taken on june the first
instead it was postponed till july the
1st 2021
so while we have this huge stock of
closed oil reserves
i mean oil whales where production has
stopped
luke oil alone has curbed production on
its active
operating oil wells by 140 000 barrels
until this stock has been distributed on
the global oil market
there will be no certainty in the
medium-term future for us
so despite the current oil price being
over 70 us dollars per barrel
my company is planning its medium-term
operations based on the price
of 50 u.s dollars per barrel
you mentioned the opec plus agreement is
it worth making it open-ended
we want this agreement to stay the
reason is that as a mechanism it can
adjust production volumes from zero to
virtually any number it makes the oil
market situation more predictable
and that guarantees affordable prices
without any spikes for our customers
just remember how it's skyrocketed to a
hundred and forty dollars
it's also good for oil producers who can
draw long-term plans
should we expect the oil prices go back
to one hundred dollars per barrel in any
foreseeable future
given what has been happening over the
last four years now the prices can go
all the way to 140
again if we do not invest in the oil
industry
that's precisely why this agreement
should stay it serves the
interests of our clients
in today's circumstances do you know
what new approaches or technologies you
should develop
first what is at the top of your agenda
today the focus is on combining
conventional and non-conventional energy
sources
we don't want any revolutions when an
energy product becomes completely
discarded no
all changes should happen evolutionary
and of course you should be aware of the
local environment depending on the
continent and country you operate in
so we advocate for more well-thought-out
policies and we do support the
increasing use of renewables
it can be a good complementary force
when there is a deficit of conventional
hydrocarbons
it can also help to bring more balance
to the market
you've just attended the plenary session
with president vladimir putin what are
your takeaways
vladimir putin once again confirmed that
the taxation system
will remain unchanged stable
this will help businesses grow i hope
the ministry of finance got the message
and the tax system will be leveraged in
such a way as to boost
businesses growth
you